How Moses and Jesus are similar, how
Moses is like Jesus. Some of the
similarities and we'll do a session on
this.
Not only is Jesus from the brothers of
Moses, but let me show you
the ways Moses and Jesus resemble each
other. And Lord willing, I'll do an
in-depth session just on this.
I already gave you some parallels in the
first session earlier. Make all these
sessions go viral for the glory of the
Lord, please, guys. But just quick
summation.
In the case of Moses and Jesus,
children were killed.
Pharaoh had the male babies killed at
the time of Moses' birth. Herod had
children two and under killed around the
time Jesus was born when he was close to
two years old. That's the first
similarity.
In both
cases, Moses and Jesus, God spoke with
both of them face to face. God came down
in a cloud on a mount to speak to Moses
directly. The Father came down in a
cloud on a mount to address Jesus and
his disciples.
Second similarity. You with me so far?
I'm just giving you a quick quick
summation. We'll go in-depth in in the
future this week, God willing, all
right?
It's all in my article.
Other similarities. Moses and Jesus
performed similar miracles. Similar
doesn't mean the same cuz Jesus is
greater than Moses, okay?
Both of them, Moses and Jesus, are
called God. Did you know that?
Another similarity between Moses and
Jesus, they're both called God. Exodus
7:1,
God says to Moses, I will make you God
to Pharaoh. I will make you Elohim to
Pharaoh. So, Moses is called God. He was
God to Pharaoh cuz he stood in the place
of God. And Jesus is God in the flesh.
That's another connection.
All of this is in my article. Okay?
Both of them are the mediator of a
covenant. Moses, the old covenant.
Jesus, the new covenant.
Both of them are priests of God. Psalm
99:6, Moses and Aaron were God's
priests. Jesus is the high priest of God
the Father in heaven.
Okay?
And I'll do a session. Both of them are
lawgivers. Moses was given the law of
God to give Israel. Jesus has given us a
law to follow. 1 Corinthians 9:21, Paul
says I'm under the law of Christ.
Galatians 6:2 says fulfill the law of
Christ.
These are just some of the many
similarities. Here's the article again.
Let's focus on Joshua.
Yehoshua.
Okay?
I gave you earlier in the first session,
Numbers 13:16,
where Moses changed the name of Hoshea
to Joshua.
The name of Hoshea to Joshua.
In fact, Arthur, yes, we can actually
show that Moses was the prince of Egypt.
And he gave it all by all up to be a
shepherd. The Lord Jesus is the prince
of heaven and earth. And he gave it all
up to come to the earth to be a
shepherd.
Right?
Moses was
a prince of Egypt, a ruler of Egypt.
And he gave it all up and became a
shepherd tending flocks for 40 years in
Midian.
Jesus is the prince of heaven and earth,
the Father's royal son, who gave up his
throne to come to the earth to be our
shepherd.
Right?
No, but his Bible's not from God.
Brethren, this Bible's not from God.
It's all corrupt. They corrupted the
Bible, son. Son, the Bible's corrupt. It
ain't the word of God. You need the
Quran. La la la la la, man. La la la la
la.
Moses gave up. Here, let me show it to
you.
Hebrews 11, Hebrews 11,
to 28. Pay attention to 26 and 27.
Hebrews 11:24-28.
Pay attention to 26 27. Go ahead,
Arthur, post that for us.
What did Moses do?
What did Moses do? Watch here. Hebrews
11:24-28.
And by the way, don't mind that we're
using modern English version. That's for
the benefit of those who don't
understand Shakespearean English. But
you know my conviction. I affirm and
love the King James Bible as God's
perfect words in English. Oh, by the
way, Catholics, you can now buy, it's
being published, King James Bible for
Catholics. It has the deuterocanonicals.
Now here, read with me. By faith, Moses,
when he became of age, refused to be
called the son of Pharaoh's daughter,
choosing rather to suffer affliction
with the people of God than to enjoy the
pleasures of sin for a time. Notice 26.
He esteemed the reproach of Christ as
greater riches than the treasures in
Egypt, for he looked to the reward. Now,
I'm going to show you what 26 means in a
minute.
By faith, he forsook Egypt, not fearing
the wrath of the king. He endured by
looking to him who is invisible. By
faith, he kept the Passover and the
sprinkling of blood, lest the one who
destroys the firstborn touch him. Did
you catch it?
By faith in Jesus Christ, Moses gave up
the riches of Egypt, his status as the
prince of Egypt, the daughter the son of
Pharaoh's daughter. He gave it all up to
join with the people of God and suffer
reproach and humiliation for the sake of
Christ.
But you didn't catch Hebrews 11:26.
Do me a favor,
Arthur, can you quote it in the NIV? The
NIV now does a good job of capturing
Hebrews 11:26. Guys, pay attention
Hebrews 11:26.
He regarded disgrace for the sake of
Christ as of greater value than the
treasures of Egypt because he was
looking ahead to his reward.
Do you understand what you just read?
Paul, by inspiration of the Holy Spirit,
said, Moses gave up
his status
and endured shame, humiliation for the
sake of Christ who had appeared to him.
Paul is telling you it was Christ that
appeared to Moses.
He saw Christ, the invisible one.
He said it right there. Let me further
show you where Paul says this. This is
going to tie with Joshua.
Go to 1 Corinthians 10:1-4.
You can go back to the modern English
version, brother.
I'll tell you when to switch. Go back to
the modern English version.
Okay?
Okay, 1 Corinthians 10:1-4.
Who appeared to Moses? Whom did Moses
worship and love and follow and give up
everything for? Here you go.
1 Corinthians 10:1-4.
Watch here, guys.
No, this book is not from God.
I would not want you to be unaware that
all our fathers were under the cloud and
all passed through the sea,
and all were baptized into Moses,
baptized meaning united to Moses as
their head, in the cloud that followed
them and in the sea. Now, watch who was
there in the cloud that followed Moses
and Israel and guided them. All ate the
same spiritual food and all drank the
same spiritual drink, for they drank of
that spiritual rock that followed them,
and that rock was Christ.
DID YOU CATCH IT? Paul says, the
spiritual rock that guided Moses and
Israel, sustained them and fed them,
preserved them, was Christ.
What do you mean, Mac, baby? What do you
mean? But now watch this. You remember
the story? We're not going to quote it
here. Numbers 21:4-9.
Do you remember the story where the
Israelites murmured because there was no
meat?
And God sent fiery serpents to bite them
dead cuz they angered the Lord God.
And then they asked Moses to to ask God
to heal them of the venomous bites. So,
God had Moses fashion the bronze
serpent. And whoever looked to the
bronze serpent would be healed. It's
Numbers 21:4-9, not 29. Numbers 21:4-9,
right? You remember that? In Numbers 21,
they tempted the Lord God and he sent
snakes to bite them and kill them dead,
right?
Okay, but now 1 Corinthians 10:9. 1
Corinthians 10:9.
Watch this so I can make another
connection. 1 Corinthians 10:9.
Watch here.
Nachashim seraphim. Neither let us tempt
Christ, as some of them also tempted and
were destroyed by serpents. Neither let
us tempt Christ, as some of them also
tempted and were destroyed by serpents.
Who did they tempt at the time of Moses?
They tempted Christ. And Christ sent the
serpents to bite them dead. What?
What do you mean,
Did you catch it?
1 Corinthians 10:4 and 9 back to back. 1
Corinthians 10:4 and 9 back to back.
Watch here.
So, you can see who was there.
1 Corinthians 10:4 and verse 9, back to
back, Arthur. Watch here.
And all drank the same spiritual drink,
for they drank of that spiritual rock
that followed them, and that rock was
Christ. Neither let us tempt Christ as
some of them also tempted and were
destroyed by serpents. Could Paul be any
clearer? Jesus was there,
consciously alive,
guiding Israel, preserving Israel,
feeding Israel, punishing Israel at the
time of Moses, cuz he is that Jehovah
God, the angel of Jehovah, who appeared
with the Father and the Spirit, and he's
the one who sent the serpents to bite
them.
So, who sent the serpents to kill them
dead?
Jesus.
Now, why then did Jesus simply not heal
them of the venomous bites? Why did he
make it so complicated, telling Moses,
"Moses, fashion a bronze serpent, and
whoever looks to the image will be
healed." Let me show you why. Go to John
3:14-15.
John 3:14-15.
But hold on.
Let me explain to you. You said
foreshadowing is cross, right? Okay. But
watch here. Just as
Moses lifted up
the serpent in the wilderness, even so
must the Son of Man be lifted up, that
whoever believes in him should not
perish, but that but have the but may
have eternal life. Now, notice what
Jesus did. He deliberately had Moses
fashion a bronze serpent, cuz he was
going to design that to be a picture of
him being lifted up on the cross to heal
us.
So, it was Jesus who had him fashion a
bronze serpent, cuz Jesus intended to
use that to point to him being lifted up
on the cross. Jesus did that.
[Music]
What do you make?
Makin' beauties.
What do you make? Makin'
Now, how does it tie to Jesus' death on
the cross as healing us?
How does this tie in with Jesus? Okay.
What killed the Israelites? Pay
attention, guys. What killed the
Israelites? The serpents, right? The
fiery serpents, right?
Okay?
So, why an image of a bronze serpent?
Because that's a sign
that the cause of your death is being
nailed, the cause of your death is being
put to death.
The serpent that's the cause of your
death is being killed,
being put to death, being mortified.
You get it?
The mortification
of the agent of your death, the serpent.
So, why is Jesus hanging on the cross?
Because sin brings human death. So, the
cause of your death is being taken
upon Jesus in his body, and then being
mortified on the cross,
dead and buried with him.
That which caused you to die is sin. So,
he takes this thing of sin and nails it
on the cross and buries it in the
ground.
He mortifies the cause of your death.
What do you make?
Makin' beauties.
And the makers.
But let me add a further connection.
Let me add a further connection.
If you look at the Hebrew, the word for
fiery serpents is
ha nahashim, plural of nahash, ha
seraphim.
Okay.
Let me repeat again.
The words for fiery serpent is ha
nahashim, the serpents, ha seraphim,
also translated serpents, fiery
serpents.
Nahashim.
Singular, nahash. Genesis 3, the word
for Satan there, the word for serpent is
nahash.
Nahash. So, here you take the nahash
that brought death into the world by
causing Adam and Eve to sin, and then
nailing him on the cross,
mortifying him on the pole, removing him
by nailing him to the pole.
You get it?
Nahash.
The word for serpent. Genesis 3, the
nahash, the serpent. Revelation 12:9,
Revelation 20:2. That serpent is the
devil, that that serpent is Satan. So,
by showing the image of a bronze serpent
that's impaled or mortified on a pole,
the imagery is the cause of your death,
the one who instigated
human death by causing Adam and Eve to
sin, he's now being removed away, he's
being nailed to the cross, he's being
mortified, he's been taken out of the
picture.